i'm at a supermarket in hong kong and
the shelves are empty at some stores
they've started limiting how much you
can buy staples like canned food or
toilet paper
panic buying is just one way people in
hong kong have reacted as the government
has put in draconian restrictions to
control the fast spreading omicron
variant
for about two years the city largely
shut out covert 19 but it has been
fighting a record surge in cases that's
overwhelmed hospitals
a low vaccination rate among the elderly
has also driven its death rate to the
highest in the world
[Music]
so here's how everyday life in hong kong
has changed and why many are rushing to
leave asia's global hub
in the city daily life has become
complicated forcing many to re-evaluate
hong kong as home
vaccine passports are now required to
get around the city and the unvaccinated
corn shop in supermarkets and malls
summer break for students started
earlier in march instead of july because
the government closed school so they
could be converted into testing and
isolation centers
gyms are shut too and people can't eat
out after 6 p.m which has hurt a lot of
businesses
this is hong kong central business
district around lunch time restaurants
used to be busy with bankers and lawyers
but these days it's pretty quiet and a
lot of restaurants and stores have had
to shut government resources have also
been pulled to battle the outbreak
authorities have been quickly building
temporary hospitals and massive
isolation sites
there's also a dedicated taxi fleet to
ferry district to clinics
but some government proposals which have
been integral to china's ability to
quickly tame covert spikes have sparked
panic among residents
in late february local health
authorities said the government couldn't
rule out whether to impose a city-wide
lockdown to test the entire population
fearing the worst residents scrambled to
stock upon everything from toiletries to
food leaving many store shelves empty
a few days later the city's chief
executive said there were no plans for a
wholesale lockdown
instead she said the government's
priority would be reducing the number of
deaths and severe illnesses
but the government's messaging hasn't
been enough to convince many residents
to stay
this is central station it used to be
one of hong kong's busiest metro stops a
few months ago it was bustling and this
emptiness now is just one sign of the
sheer number of people the city is
losing
according to immigration data nearly 69
000 more hong kong residents have left
the city and arrived this year with
almost 80 percent of those leaving in
february as the city's pandemic controls
kicked into full gear
hong kong officials have called for calm
and reassured residents there would be
enough supplies of food and essentials
but as pressure from business groups has
mounted authorities in late march said
the city would scrap flight ban from
some countries and cut quarantine for
returning residents from 14 days to
seven
the government also said it would relax
some social distancing rules from april
but china is also facing its biggest
outbreak since the start of the pandemic
and authorities they have kicked into
action by ordering millions to stay home
and restricting travel
however chinese president xi jinping has
vowed to reduce the impact of those
measures on the economy and on people's
lives
health authorities have also said that
patients with no symptoms or mild ones
should go to isolation facilities
freeing up space in hospitals
it's a small step in easing restrictions
but as long as hong kong remains aligned
with china's policies life in the city
won't return to normal until the number
of cases are under control